involved but i would urge british
nationals in the area to listen to the
advice of the las vegas authorities
prime minister thank you very much
thank you
this morning the sheriff of clark county
nevada briefed reporters we'll also hear
from nevada's governor attorney general
and other officials this is about 30
minutes
well good morning everyone
for those of you that don't know i am
sheriff lombardo for clark county
i don't have very much more to update
you with
from our previous briefings
one thing in particular that has changed
in the negative is our body count
you know what that's the wrong way to
say it the number of people that have
died associated with this event has
increased
right now we're using the number of 58.
i just was informed that it may be 59 of
an individual that may have expired at
sunrise hospital so
in normal fashion i do not want to give
you bad information
so please do not press me on that number
until we get further into this
investigation
the number of injured
we are using the number of 515
and as you can tell as the hours go by
that number continues to increase
we have not received any additional
intelligence associated with the suspect
we are we have completed the search
warrant in mesquite
i am not aware of any derogatory
information that we can utilize to
furtherance of this investigation at
this point
but we have just recovered items and it
will take a little while to evaluate
that information
we have learned information of
additional property in northern nevada
and the fbi has responded to the
location and will be serving a search
warrant here shortly
we have completed the investigation at
the room
we have collected all the items
associated with the suspect and we are
in the recovery phase of that the
mandalay bay itself
has gone back to service a minus the
32nd floor
and they would like everybody advised
that if they are
separated from their hotel room they
have the ability to return to the hotel
now the
location in question the concert hall
we will be in a long process of body
recovery out there and evidence recovery
and evidence documentation so you're
going to have to ask the public's
patience
and as we bring information forward
it's a
long laborious process to identify the
victims and reunite them
with the family members to advise them
of their situation so
we still have the families responding to
the las vegas metropolitan police
department headquarters in order to to
conduct a reunification of their family
or friends
eventually
in the next few hours actually i'm i
don't want to give you a a skewed
timeline but approximately 1 pm we will
request the family members to respond to
the convention area
convention center area to utilize a
larger space
and we could bring in the
victim advocates
to assist with the family members in the
long term
right now it's just a temporary phase
associated with the reunification
additionally
we're asking to solely utilize a united
blood service for blood donation and
umc
as the only places to donate blood we
had some resource issues associated with
the laborers
medical clinic i applaud their effort to
help us in that effort but we have some
resource issues associated with that
so better utilize lvmpd.com
to ensure that you know where those
united blood service locations are
so we can get the needed life-saving
blood
for the victims associated with this
at this point as you can tell i have
several
individuals to my rear that would like
to make comment
reference the isis statement i want to
bring that up now
so i give the opportunity to special
agent rouse to respond to that from the
fbi
and he will explain what we know now
reference isis claiming this
individual
thank you
good morning
as this event unfolds we have determined
to this point
no connection with an international
terrorist group as this investigation
continues
we will continue to work with our
partners to ensure that this is
factually thoroughly and absolutely
investigated to be able to bring comfort
and peace
back to this community thank you
good morning my name is ruben kiewen i'm
the congressman for the 4th
congressional district here in nevada
i just want to say thank you to law
enforcement
and to all the first responders
who
are now
fighting tirelessly to protect and save
lives
i had the opportunity to stop by sunrise
hospital earlier this morning
i saw firsthand a lot of the victims a
lot of the family members
but i also saw a lot of nurses and
doctors
that were working tirelessly to save
lives
and today is a very sad day for nevada
it's a very sad day for las vegas
but if anything good came out of this is
that i saw humanity i saw our community
come together i saw strangers helping
strangers and saving lives and so i do
want to say thank you to the sheriff and
to metro police uh to firefighters the
doctors the nurses and everybody who has
worked entirely to save lives
at this precise moment i know we're
going to get through this and our city
will be stronger thank you so much
i'm clark county district attorney steve
wolfson and on behalf of the clark
county da's office uh our thoughts and
prayers go out to
everybody associated with this event
two of my prosecutors two of my young
female prosecutors were actually
at this concert close to the stage
and i've spoken to both of them this
morning and they're pretty rattled
they're pretty shaken up
this was a horrific event to say the
least this is
a classic wmd this is a
a weapon and a man of mass destruction
what i'm pleased so much about is how
this doesn't involve politics in the
sense of republican or democrat
we are here all of us are nevadams
and i'm very proud to be present with
the other leaders here because we're
working together
to get through this
i want to thank sheriff lombardo for
your leadership in leading us through
this terrible terrible day thank you
thank you
thank you sheriff i want to first off
begin by thanking the sheriff he uh i
got down here eight or nine hours ago
there weren't many of us here eight or
nine hours ago it was just a handful
immediately after this incident but
i can tell you that our first responders
both the fire men and women of the fire
department
and metro were on their way in when
this all happened we've got first
responders that are literally covered in
blood
as a result of this a lot of victims
have not been identified as at this
point but they have stepped up it was a
sole shooter there is uh no further
threat that we're aware of no immediate
threat i want to assure everyone that's
listening that here's our words that las
vegas is safe the men and women of
mandalay bay and mgm resorts have been
incredible in terms of communicating and
working with the sheriff's office in
order to assure us that everybody can
you know be taken care of get back into
the rooms and that they all understand
that we are safe and we are doing
everything humanly possible to protect
all our tourists and our citizens in
clark county
that being said the sheriff and i have
set up a gofundme account that some of
you might have seen uh we appreciate
been inundated with phone calls and
emails and text messages people asking
what they can do
there's gonna be a lot of family members
that are going through an awful lot at
this particular time as the sheriff said
we have over 500
in our hospitals being treated and we
need to provide them with some sort of
support so we have done that and i just
can't say enough about the
fine men and women
that are our first responders here in in
clark county and all of the cities and
jurisdictions have pulled together and i
thank them all for that we've pledged
your full resources of clark county to
assist the sheriff and the fbi in any
way humanly possible it will be a
disservice and we uh ask for your
prayers god bless you
i want to thank you all our mayor carol
and goodman of this great city
and absolutely mirror what commissioner
sisselak had spoken to about the great
response rapid thorough of our first
responders in law enforcement i spent
part of last night and was late this
morning with you all because i was over
at umc in the trauma unit and
it's been a very very difficult time for
us and as we look forward to continuing
what our great city does
we offer a safe place
this is a crazed lunatic full of hate we
don't know much about his background but
it certainly is not an extension of what
we believe in what everybody who lives
here and works here and those who visit
here want to see this is something that
was simply outrageous uncalled for and
so many innocent people young people
children
parents who've lost loved ones and so
many still suffering in the hospitals
gone through major surgery we have some
that were hit quite lightly with
shrapnel as they were near the exits
it's been a hugely traumatic time for
all of us and for our visitors who love
country music many of whom have come
from the northern part of our states
here and just really
came here for a wonderful safe time we
pride ourselves in our law enforcement
they are unequal they are so rapid to
respond so thorough on what they do and
our our first responders have been
simply phenomenal it is a city and a
community that has pulled together
everybody is working so hard to make
sure that we are taking care of the
needs of the families and those who've
lost loved ones
and it's just been a very very traumatic
time for everybody the president gave a
beautiful message and he will be
visiting us either sometime later today
tomorrow or wednesday
great concern and we just know that the
entire community i have so many mayors
that have called governors who have
called me personally to express their
support help and what we ask for is
blood that's the main thing right now is
that if our people want to do something
and they are healthy then please donate
blood we'll have plenty of banks
available always call a hospital if
you're unsure where to go so thank you
very much and madam congresswoman i'm
sorry i didn't mean to step in front of
you can always go before me mayor it's a
pleasure to follow you
well thank you very much i'm dena titus
i represent nevada's district one it
includes the fabulous las vegas strip
including the mandalay bay where this
horrendous act took place you know so
many times i welcome people to las vegas
and all the excitement and entertainment
and fun it has to offer never thought
i'd be standing here trying to offer
solace and my office assistance to
victims of something like this that
would happen
all through the night we were briefed by
law enforcement i thank you sheriff and
your team for all that you did and the
first responders mainly we were trying
to stay out of the way because you don't
want to turn a personal tragedy into a
political event today my office will be
giving blood as the mayor said they
appreciate your thoughts and prayers but
what they need is blood
we'll be open to do anything we can to
assist but you know i've just been
hearing all these stories of heroism
that occurred in the midst of this
tragedy you had off-duty police officers
who were there just for the concert for
an evening of fun who were able to help
people get shelter and who were able to
identify the location of the shooter and
just random strangers a friend of some
of my staff members who lives in the
district said they were running being
trampled somebody just opened a van door
and pulled them inside for shelter and
safety that's the kind of people we have
here in las vegas who are willing to
reach out and help one another and so i
thank all of our law enforcement i think
the first responders those in the
hospitals where people are just in the
halls in the parking lot trying to take
care of so many and please call on our
office if there's any way we can be of
assistance
i'm adam laxalt nevada's attorney
general
and
i want to echo a lot of people said
today i've been here since about two in
the morning
and the job that metro and our law
enforcement first responders have done
is just absolutely remarkable
we've never been hit with such a tough
situation in this city and to see the
poise
and the uh pressure that they're able to
perform under was was truly astounding
i i believe that they're always going to
be able to get us out of these
situations our law enforcement will be
able to step up to the plate when we
need the most and of course
the city and our state will bounce back
thank you very much
thank you
i just want to add one more thing before
we ask the governor come up
i got to ask you to do something else
when you see one of these men or women
wearing a badge
or members of our fire department tell
them thank you
their selfless actions save the lives of
hundreds of people not a dozen people
hundreds of people this death count
would have been
many hundred more words not for the
brave work of every single one of these
men and women that you see wearing a
badge members of our fire department our
first responders our police department
so please i encourage all of you
watching next time you see one just say
thank you
appreciate that
good morning ladies and gentlemen i'm
governor brian sandoval
you know i don't know if i have words to
describe
what we're going through and what these
poor unfortunate victims are going
through
we're angry
we're grieving
i'm confused
people are hurting
i want to thank the sheriff and all the
first responders
i just had an opportunity to visit some
of the patients in the hospital
and
it's unimaginable what people are going
through right now
you know you got family members who are
here and don't have anyone to reach out
to
but the first responders and what
they've done
it's their finest hour
their finest hour
and the way that the sheriff and the
metropolitan police department have
handled this event
is unprecedented
the paramedics
who came on the scene
and basically what was a war zone
and treated all those
men women and kids
the health care professionals at the
hospitals the doctors who came from all
over the valley
to do whatever they could
and now
you know
we don't understand what's happened
and i'm sure we'll find out a little
more from when
metro continues to do
its investigation
i do know for everybody watching and you
know i want to thank the president of
the united states the other governors
that have reached out to me to offer
their help and assistance
we need blood
so if anybody can contribute blood
anybody in the las vegas area or locally
who can do that
but as we move on we'll learn more
we're going to need this help
now this is obviously an unprecedented
event in our nation's history and we're
going to have to learn from this
we're going to have to fight through
this
we have to stop
and pray
for the families and for the victims
we have to rely on our faith in a time
like this
to get us through all of it
you know i'm
i couldn't be prouder of the way that
nevadans have responded to this
and in what they've done
doctors and nurses and
everyone else who's worked through the
night
to save lives
and they've told me they've saved lives
that that if not for
their organization and their
professionalism and their training
so again sheriff thank you
for the courage
that you've shown
to the people that were at the concert
you you see courage and compassion there
people helping total strangers
risking their own lives
to help people that really speaks
highly
to the character of america
so again
there's a lot to learn from all this it
was a
cowardly despicable act
that
i'm very angry about
there's not much we can do but we can
learn
so ladies and gentlemen
thank you for everybody's care and
concern
i said
you know i'm really proud to be with
everybody who's here the mayor the
congressman the attorney general the
sheriff the congressman
our law enforcement
this is the nevada family at its best so
god bless all of you
and god bless most importantly
the families
the victims the mothers the fathers the
sons the daughters the aunts the uncles
cousins nephews nieces friends
and neighbors
and for everybody who's watching
please stop for a moment and pause and
say a prayer for them thank you
hold on a second
i'll take questions here just shortly
um
as you can see uh we had the opportunity
to have some of the nevada's delegation
here today and some are missing
but i don't want them slighted because
they all reached out to me
senator heller senator masto and uh
congresswoman rosen they all reached out
to me throughout this
tragedy and offered their assistance so
i don't want them slightly just because
they're not standing behind me
additionally i have a chief of police
next to me and that's chief troy tanner
of the mesquite pd he has been
instrumental in the assistance of his
folks towards us to help us complete
this investigation so i think it's
appropriate that he gets recognized for
their effort
and then
greg castle he's just very humble he's
obviously the clark county fire chief
and he likes to stand in the back but
where we are different in our
jurisdiction as through my travels in
comparison to other jurisdictions
we work very well with the fire
department and they did not hesitate to
pair up with an officer and enter the
fray so i want to thank him for that
thank you greg
so i'm happy to answer some questions um
as you know the investigation is
continuing
so please do not get too detailed on
your questions because i probably will
not be able to answer it at this time
sure
yes sir
now this the second location is just
based off assessors records of ownership
uh we discovered that he owned another
piece of property in the orders of
nevada as far as the
electronic evaluation we haven't had the
opportunity to do that yet the only
thing we are immediately aware in our
position is additional firearms and
ammunition
uh people who hit with shrapnel at the
exit that's what mayor goodman said i
want you to follow up on that and also
how did you get these weapons into the
hotel room
um well we're like i said we're doing
the investigation i don't want to give
you any inaccurate information but we do
know that he brought the weapons in on
his own
an original uh briefing we believe that
he was in
partnership or companionship of a female
and we have determined the female is out
of the country uh so he brought these
weapons in on his own
as far as method i don't have the
ability to give you an accurate picture
was the shooter known to local law
enforcement here in clark county or las
vegas any prior charge
no not at all
we've checked all the federal databases
and local databases and state databases
and we had no knowledge of this
individual
sheriff are we going to change the
designation on the woman who was
involved
in a person of interest or
suspect
uh no it's still a we still consider her
a person of interest we have been in
contact with her and we plan to engage
her upon her return to the country have
any idea how he was able to
break through the windows it was able to
open the windows or did he smash the
windows
we believe he had a device similar to a
hammer to smash the windows
uh sharon
so far i've heard a description of the
suspect has a lonely
investigation look
looking into any potential ties even
loose ties to extremist groups well
obviously we'll do that we will
run it down to the very end
but right now at face value we haven't
been able to identify that
sure he's checked in on from
the 28th to the hotel i believe that's
accurate did he have tickets to the
concert i have no idea so you know what
he has done between checking in and and
now we're we're following up on that
there will be hours and hours and hours
of video surveillance that we will have
to recall with the cooperation of the
mgm
your center upstairs where you keep um
you know
the fusion center correct um there are
cameras everywhere exactly every
interview is covering the camera our
doors being board
how did this happen
well i i understand um what you're
alluding to how could it happen this is
an individual that was described as a
lone wolf i don't know how it could have
been prevented if we didn't have any
prior knowledge to this individual um it
wasn't evident that he had weapons in
his room we have determined that there
has been
employees
going to and fro from his room and
nothing nefarious was noticed at this
point that's what we know
death can you now how multi-agency
effort and strike teams were able to
find the suspect
well yeah you're absolutely correct so
any special event that takes place in
the southern nevada region
it's required by nrs to supply police
officers
to ensure security
the mandalay bay did a
great job of hiring police officers they
had sufficient staffing
for the staff for the concert
and when this individual decided to fire
upon the crowd which was approximately
22 000 individuals
it's very difficult to manage that size
crowd and you have to ensure you have
the proper staffing
and as described
our officers responded immediately in
conjunction with the fire department as
soon as the fire department arrived
but they were able to identify where the
weapon was being discharged from in part
in a proximity
it's hard to tell what floor it is from
the outside but once they gain entry
into the hotel
in conjunction with security and through
phone calls from patrons they were able
to
call it down to a possible floor
once they made
entry onto the hallway they could they
immediately knew what room was in
question
sure there's some dramatic reports about
what exactly happened in the room when
swat officers entered that maybe there
was so much smoke from the shells that
the smoke alarms were going off is there
any truth any of that i don't know i
haven't been told about any smoke alarms
but i know
that his
he had killed himself
and exactly
we'll have to go through the
our
body-worn camera and existing video uh
whether we uh engaged him at the same
approximate time or not
no ma'am i can't get into the mind of a
psychopath at this point
sheriff on the investigation that's
going on right now between uh at the
site of the shooting
how extensive is it and what are we
talking about as far as los angeles
boulevard being shut down
while the ballistics and the criminals
do their work out there well i believe
um we've got most of las vegas boulevard
open um directly adjacent to the
mandalay um it still remains closed
we'll ensure that we go out to the the
proper intersections to
to limit the hindrance of traffic
but we're looking at a minimum of 12
additional hours for documentation and
of the crime scene and the removal of
the bodies do you know about how long he
was able to shoot for and do you have to
know if there was ever any return fire
from officer on the ground in any way no
i don't i'm not aware of any return fire
nor am i aware of the timeline
but we did have swat officers discharged
weapons
at the room location the idea of
checking
yes the the federal or the fbi and the
atf is uh helping us with that aspect
injured or deceived from the hotel were
they all in the concert or running in
the
hotel area
i'm not sure because we had people that
were deceased and injured outside the
vicinity of the concert area so it'd be
hard to determine or make that
determination at this point we're
obviously going to have to talk to all
those
injured individuals to make that
assessment
i don't know ma'am
the people have been displaced in five
separate hospitals so it's going to
require an extensive review of that
communication with them
to determine it so
thank you very much i appreciate
everybody's time and i appreciate
everybody here to the back of me and
their support of our police department
and
we will keep you regularly updated i
can't give you an exact timeline at this
point
but we will keep you informed as we
receive information have a great day
thank you